thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another fantastic
episode of those careful boys that was
careful boys well we are currently off
the Record and today we are talking
about daddy issues but not just for
girls daddy you shoot boys I believe is
what we're talking about what the [__]
is that by the way daddy issues
everybody talks about daddy issue a
little bit I think everybody talks about
daddy issue girls but they never
mentioned what about the guys is that
right I feel like we've talked about
your daddy if she was like 18 times on
this show no but like a troll thing like
with the whole world's not talking about
like this do you think your daddy issues
correlate to a relationship like your
friendships and your intimate
relationships and how so yeah problem
yeah can you give us an example Trope of
like the dad the son and then the
example Trope of a daddy issue girl is
someone who has no real idea of what um
a father or male should act like so they
imagine that person and they never can
get that person that they imagine and
then they they also try to confine an
older men because they need the
replacement of the Daddy's love it's
like a dependence yeah so that's the
that's the whole kind of stereotype of
like oh she got Daddy Issues that's why
she's always going for like older dudes
that are like you know whatever or
whatever you know no Trusted Man or
whatever it is yeah then what might be a
Trope and or stereotype of a daddy issue
for a guy in an Asian household all
Asian household I think I think for for
me it's like the
because my dad was so seldomly
expressive about being satisfied with
anything that I did that carries over I
think I think you you have to
like seek so much reassurance from a
girl in the beginning I was like that I
always needed who I was dating to have
some sign that she still liked me even
though nothing changed but I would be
very like dependent on like hey like
what's going on am I still cool with you
like are you still interested yeah but
it's like that's so annoying but that's
because of my dad never expressing that
so I always felt like I needed to check
in so lack of control yeah a result of
maybe that I think you just you're just
not confident that you're doing okay
because no one was ever telling you that
it was like hey you're doing great kid
you know reassurance or whatever yeah
yeah oh interesting and a lot of Asian
dads are like that they're very like
Stern they're very like they're not
they're not warm you know yeah yeah yeah
so you don't know how to communicate
properly yeah you think something's
wrong if if nothing if nothing's
happening at all you think it's default
bad mm-hmm yeah interesting because I
never really thought about daddy issues
if your dad stuck around but I can see
that too because it's more like
having that weird
relationship but did you have
abandonment issues I I would say
I I don't know if I have full-on daddy
issues because I had my father up until
14. oh okay and then so like
at that age I'm kind of I don't I
wouldn't say full grown but like you
know your formidable years so like I
don't I'm not
I'm not growing up like wondering how
like a two two like two parent household
would work like because they did that as
a child and then we did have normal
stuff
I would just say like maybe the biggest
thing I probably took away from that was
every time there was an argument or it
didn't work out then like it was easy to
leave or then leave me it was just like
you don't really stick around yeah okay
so it was like the abandonment was like
probably my way of like oh yeah it's
just not gonna work out but then when I
was with girls who have both parents
like for them it's like oh it's we can
work through this or if you have an
argument you still stick around or
whatever it's not like it's all over
yeah yeah
but I wouldn't know really I think I
think when Colleen brought it up and
said like guys with daddy issues I was
like oh that's interesting because I
don't really think about
yeah you don't think about that yeah so
like what's the common thing yeah that
you see in guys with daddy issues that
you see a pattern of I think they
overcompensate for what they think
masculinity should be
so well then I'm for sure got daddy
issues you know what I'm saying
wait what what am I that is hot
I'm so attractive
it works yeah
um so like for instance like
kind of piggybacking off of your
experience like the lack of control or
feeling like they have a lack of control
or like guys who immediately go to like
I want a woman who submits to me but
they don't last time no what that means
um yeah so yeah I think it's like a lack
of true understanding of what real
masculinity is because it they never had
the example that's true yeah
so yeah because some people would call
um they would misunderstand submitting
as just pure passive agreeableness
correct so if they don't have that then
they have a lot of troll which means a
lack of masculinity which then yeah I
could see that the relationship Dynamic
gets a little you know
skewed if you say some stupid [__]
people are gonna TR they should people
close to you should challenge your
thoughts and and your and your reasoning
and stuff no a woman should never speak
I agree are you Asian what the [__] I
think you're right that's pretty true
women should never speak they should
always cool I'll just see myself but no
we need that mouth dog
I think you're right though I think like
lack of control was a big thing now that
I look back my first like few
relationships I was super obsessed with
like maintaining some form of control
whether it was false or whatever I just
needed to like always I was the kind of
guy that like if my girlfriend went out
without me I was like I had anxiety I
was like oh [__] like she's probably
gonna meet somebody he's probably way
harder than me if I could have more
money he's probably gonna have a better
car like it sucked to live like that to
be like oh my gosh she's gonna leave me
it's like a lack of respect for you
right like you feel like she's not
expecting you in a certain way because
you're not receiving what you want to
receive out of the the lack of control
that you don't have yeah I think it
really is just like a it's it is a daddy
issue because I think for me my dad
didn't make me feel confident like for
some weird reason I think my dad just
thought it was like like being confident
was like an earned thing but then he
wouldn't give me a fair shot he would
just be like oh you gotta get through me
to be confident kind of thing so if I'm
like if he's making fun of me or like
jabbing me then it's like that's on me
if I took it personal so then I grew up
with that feeling of like oh man I'm not
good enough and then when you try to
have a relationship and you're not good
with yourself then that [__] is just
what comes out and it sucks yeah
I feel kind of Lucky where
um after my dad left I still had father
figures like I like the church yeah like
I have my uncle who was so the thing is
my both my dad and my uncle had
positions of
well it kind of seems to be power like
he's my dad sings at the church right so
there's an audience and then my uncle
he's a pastor at the church oh there's
an audience so they're kind of like yeah
in front of a stage
yeah and then there were uh like my
cousin he's the oldest cousin out of the
group he's like 20 years older than me
but um he was super business he is
business savvy and then he earns like
well and then he always helped out the
family financially
so there were different things of good
examples of what how guys should take
care of each other yeah but then looking
back
most of those father figures have daddy
issues so like my dad's dad as soon as
he was born
um his mom died in his death so then he
need to immediately remarry so then
because like if if you have like what 14
kids right you need somebody to take all
those kids and he was working as a
company exec so he had to be married he
couldn't be single it's bad for image
all right yeah yeah yeah so then he grew
up just with different caretakers and
then my uncle his
mom was getting beat up and and and and
all that abused so then he she took him
and they ran away and lived in a [__]
Barn
until she remarried [__] yeah so then
they didn't really have
got that's probably why they grew up so
[__] up too so it's like the blind
leading the blind so I'm like sometimes
I think we look at our fathers and and
and hope they had all the answers and
guidance but then when you get to a
certain point you realize they're
working it out too and they just don't
know yeah so you're saying all dads have
had daddy issues and their dads had a
daddy issue it's like it just gets in my
in my circle yeah except for my cousin I
think he had both parents and they're
pretty solid people but
um I would say like but that's not blood
relative so everybody else I would say
is like where where was your where was
your dad born Tokyo don't you think
though like I I know that we're talking
about the specific subject of like daddy
issues and stuff like that but like I
think I even asked about like the Asian
household and stuff like that because I
also feel as a first generation Asian
American there's also this like
generational change in this Gap like in
terms of the way that people were even
raised yeah oh yeah no one says I love
you there's no verbal like but that's
what I'm saying even even the idea that
like uh same thing like my dad is uh the
fourth oldest kid amongst uh 12 brothers
and sisters right so I imagine the idea
of like the attention that his father
might have been able to give him amongst
like 12 brothers and sisters versus me
sitting over here in America being like
I'm your one and only son how come I'm
not getting you know what I'm saying
like because maybe he wasn't fed that
same type of life and or communication
but then it's like
besides just daddy issue it's also like
well that was a totally different
lifestyle yeah you know what I'm saying
like out here in our generation nobody's
trying to have [__] 12 kids anymore
right it's just a different mentality
it's a different lifetime yeah and same
with us when we're you know as we're
growing up we're thinking about having
children we're not thinking about that
same type of no way so you know what I'm
saying like there's a whole shift yeah
it's hard for them and mentality because
they're trying to raise an American kid
and they were never American yeah I
think that's a huge one too because like
we see all of our friends who are more
Americanized and their parents may be
more educated or maybe more emotionally
like intelligent maybe more self-aware
so like they might have a different up
upbringing and you're just like kind of
jealous of that I remember thinking that
like why the [__] are their families
more like reasonable and sensible and
why the [__] do I have a bunch of
cavemen in my family that just like
throw Fist and yell all the time you
know yeah for sure so how do you fix
your daddy issues if you can't repair
that relationship with their father
if that's not the circumstance
um for me I think it was being able well
I don't even know if I'm fully fixed but
I think it's you have to see the
patterns that you're continuing so I
noticed that like we're like
sponges right we'll absorb some things
that they do and then we'll do it but in
a different way for example let's say
they were physically abusive
I might not be physically abusive so I'm
just like yeah man like I'm good I'm not
abusive but then I could be verbally
abusive and and not know that I'm doing
the same [__] but in a different way
yeah so then I think if you can catch
that and then
kind of it always appears when you're
not in control yeah it's like your
default like status when you're not
really uh what is it called uh logical
yeah and then think of all the areas
that you want to improve in probably
that it's like maybe if you want to be
more verbal and in the way you express
your love and you just never understood
how to do that and then the only way to
do it is seek out people that do it well
yeah yeah so you know what's a really
sad thing that hit me when I like turned
30 was I I thought about my dad and I
was like is he was he really that bad of
a dad and then I think about it and I'm
like yeah he wasn't the softest person
he wasn't very like empathetic he's very
hard but he was a really good provider
and then I think about that and I'm like
I started to be afraid that I might
become the inverse of him or I'm just a
[__] cool ass dad but I'm also a
deadbeat cool ass dad and that I feel
that destroyed me because I'm like I
still can't match up to how good of a
provider my dad was was he that bad of a
dad and is being a great dad but not a
good provider also a bad dad yeah you
know what I mean which one would I
rather have that's so true a dad that
was just intuited by emotions but
couldn't buy me [__] private school
yeah which one so busy being a provider
you may not have time to be the best dad
yeah and I think that's what happens a
lot of the times and especially like
like for my parents right my mom was a
stay-at-home my dad was working a lot
and I think growing up
I would hear Rumblings from my my uh my
mom and my sisters about like you know
they would complain about my dad like
not doing this not doing that so so when
I grew up so much of my messaging was
like oh negative negative negative then
as I got older and I kind of pulled the
lens back then you realize like oh
this is just their point of view on the
whole entire situation but they're not
taking account all the other stuff that
was like yeah he's the one that has to
work he has to provide for all of us
right and yeah you know sometimes that
balance isn't there but at the time
that's like the kind of the the roles of
everyone in the house so it's like
that's what he has to do yeah and then
kind of like what you said like I'm in
that phase right now too where I'm like
in my head growing up I would always
hear you know my dad was like a bad dad
or whatever the [__] right whatever kind
of negative messaging out here
and then um
since then you just pull the lens back
and then you realize like oh it's not
necessarily he's a bad dad but it's just
just a messaging and I think that's the
the
that's what you look at the person yeah
yeah it's like that's that was their
view on it right right and separating
that from who you are and how you see it
is totally different so when you
experience something similar to it yeah
he might have gone through you start
realizing whoa there's way more
variables to this and I have oh of
course and this detours my ability to
connect
it's the variables I think there's a
social cost to being a good provider
definitely and I think that's the part
that we were like oh man dad's not as
cool as the dad on TV or something
behind these movies dude that's what
you're repairing you're missing my
baseball game again Dad you gotta bring
him to Bob Saget maybe a way of like
healing that is just having a more
compassionate look oh dude for sure the
things that you're down yeah did do yeah
instead of what he didn't do right and
it's also it's gonna happen inevitably
your kid is not gonna understand
something about you right you know
you're going to be a bad dad in some way
that you thought was justifiably good
and it does take time for you know as
like you go through the seasons of life
like you know in your 20s there's one
season in your 30s another season so
it's like I think as you hit your 30s as
you work more as you experience more in
life you you see the how much more
complicated life is and it's not like
black and white and I feel like for me
in my 20s everything was black and white
to me everything was like it's either
this or that and there's no in between
yeah and then you're starting to see as
you get older and meet more people have
conversations with more people from
different walks of life you go oh [__]
this is so different and you realize
like oh [__] my life was actually so
much better than you previously thought
growing up and you go oh you're just
to learn a lot about our daddy issues
when we like choose to have children
yeah when we see the things like Joe was
saying that did get passed on or the
things that we chose not to like
replicate yeah yeah and being conscious
of that because I I've been like for
example I know I got daddy issues when I
started seeing the pattern of like when
I would watch like movies and TV shows
no matter how sad the story was or the
characters like you know hardships was I
hope I've never cried but if it was
specifically between a son and a father
I would die every time I can't last a
second wow always cheer up relatable
that's the only thing yeah you could
[__] have a massive [__] disaster
where like thousands die and I'm just
like oh that sucks and you know I saw
the others one [__] good scripted
speech between a father and son in tears
I saw you guys see that dude from
American Idol the Big Hawaiian dude yeah
no oh and I just saw it randomly and I
saw Joe Rogan this other dude talking
about it and then they played the video
clip and he's singing a song about his
dad dying and how he got him into music
and he's ambro and he sings some like
Michael Blunt song or some [__] James
whatever no Michael Black
Michael Blunt you guys familiar with it
and he sings the song bro and tell me
why at like 2 p.m in the middle of the
day I'm just like bawling bro yeah Molly
oh my God I have to show everybody I
know about this that's where you know
where your issues are like that's how
you know [__] up but I think you're
when it's like the first stage is like
you think your parents know everything
right so then it's easy to blame them
because you're going like you messed up
you could have done better and then you
you start to get older and you start to
empathize and you're like well [__] it
was hard for you guys and you didn't
have the same tools that I do
um on like self-help and all that and
then
you start going oh [__] and then you
start [__] up too and you're like oh
damn it I have these habits too yeah and
then I think that's the other thing too
you see yourself in like you're like I'm
like oh [__] I'm redoing the things that
my dad did that I didn't like growing up
and then you go oh dude that's the thing
about bad dads when you have a bad dad
that's always doing the things that are
supposedly wrong it's it's almost like
you're you're still learning from that
too so in a way yeah they're made they
may be doing bad actions but when you
grow up and you recognize these actions
they're still being taught you're still
being taught a lesson so they're
indirectly teaching you by how not to
behave yeah I mean to add on that I'm at
that point now because I think
so it's it's almost like a I think it's
like a Taoist belief right where it's
kind of Yin Yang where you can't have
the happiness without the sadness so you
can't have the lesson without the pain
yeah and so what do you expect a perfect
childhood with absolutely no trauma and
no no you can't adversity like that's
the that's that's basically the wrong
expectation right so when you blame it
when you have all these issues with the
person you're thinking you should have
done it perfectly yeah without any
issues and I would have been in such a
better place because of that but we do
see so many kids that were like tele
sheltered and hella like you know they
weren't great non-traumatic situations
and they crumble in so many situations
because they don't they never had
adversity yeah so like when I have kids
it's gonna be like yeah I'll try my best
but dude if one day I feel like you know
like maybe they'd you sometimes you
gotta treat your kids you know you gotta
smack them you got to do yeah uppercut
but like let's say you [__] up right
yeah and you end up hitting them or like
you yell at them you say things you're
not supposed to it's like yeah it's
[__] up but maybe you know hopefully
they're gonna grow up to not be you yeah
I'm not saying to do that but I'm saying
if you end up like that like a bad guy
confuse me right now are you promoting
Donuts
the crap
smack smack grab you gotta forget to
pick him up at school and smack grab
smack but like because we're not perfect
either and so when we have kids like you
can't there's no way you could
absolutely fix everything about yourself
while you're having a kid because then
you're going to be dealing with like
having a job having to have a
relationship with yours that is true
yeah there's so many things to balance
that I mean while your dad's looking
like from heaven like
like I would feel bad if I was a bad dad
but at the same time I was still trying
my best to not be one and whether
however they perceive me it's like well
that I'm just gonna have to accept that
you know I would say A good rule of
thumb is if they did better than their
own then give them a pass yeah and I
think even though I have a sociopath
[__] nut case of a father he actually
did better than his father according to
what my mom says yeah so that's that
means you know he so don't trust your
mom
so he did try and then according to you
know the the you just got to look at the
the family line not other people and
then just see within the family line
right did someone [__] it up really bad
then blame his ass but if it's like
every step it did progress then it's
like [__] it yeah that's what I'm saying
it's like as my only goal is to make
sure they're better than me when they're
older and like that's it yeah just I
just hook up
that's dramatically better myself
purposely like [__] lazy that's
that's how I coped with it I think like
oh you know what the [__] turning
point was randomly like I went to uh
Circus Circus and I was like walking
around the games area there's like this
one game you just throw a ball at a face
or whatever and the guy that was there
was like no one playing it it was like
dead the guy that was standing there
just waiting for someone to come to the
game looked dead on exactly like my dad
no way and it hit me and I went my dad
would do this
to put food on the table yeah and it hit
me like yeah my dad wasn't the best dad
in all the subjective parts of being a
father but on the required Parts he did
exactly what he was supposed to do yeah
and think about like the layers of what
he was sacrificing yeah his own like
turmoil of his own life being like I
just gotta do what I gotta do to provide
her right because that's not a thing he
has to it's not a puzzle for him it's
like make money so the kid can live like
he'd never failed at that but everything
else I'm like I can give a pass and a
lot of people fail at that and a lot of
people fail at that yeah or they don't
even want to deal with it and just
bounce like yeah and then you think back
when you're a kid you were a total piece
of [__] to your parents and you're like
God damn dude you know what it is too I
think in this Society like the bare
minimum used to be that and now it's
just like oh not only do you have to
provide but you got to be emotionally
you know I think that's honestly asking
too much and you gotta like everybody
wants you to be the perfect dad you just
gotta be better dude or just like just
the perfect human and friendships and
relationships just the expectations
exceed the appreciation yeah like or
just be you and just do your thing right
exactly
don't be yourself
oh